It's time for another edition of "Holiday Customs from around the World."
Today, you're gonna learn about a Canadian holiday called Canadian Thanksgiving.
Or if you're in Canada, Thanksgiving!
American Thanksgiving takes place on the fourth Thursday of November.
Canadian Thanksgiving takes place on the second Monday of October.
American families gather around the TV to watch American football.
Your friends to the north gather around the TV to watch Canadian football.
You won't find a nationally televised Macy's Day Parade on Canadian Thanksgiving.
But you will find the nationally televised Kitchener-Waterloo Oktoberfest Parade.
You Americans chow down on roast turkey with all the trimmings.
But we Canucks feast on roast turkey with all the trimmings.
See, the thing is, it's basically the exact same holiday except earlier.